this morning we're exploring how queen
elizabeth is putting her stamp on the
four-day party for her platinum jubilee
underway through the weekend but she has
not been able to attend every event she
withdrew from a family church service in
her honor this morning as mark phillips
reflects more and more the 96 year old
is doing things her way
it seems queens get cut a little slack
in their golden years this queen not as
steady on her feet as she used to be has
been selective in choosing which event
she'll attend during this jubilee period
and with whom she'll be seen
if a new train line named after her
needs opening she'll get a ticket to
ride she likes trains
if a horse show in her honor is going on
next door she'll show up with a smile
she likes horses
but if a long ceremonial procession is
required to open a session of parliament
she'll let one of the kids do it my
lord's pray be seated and if another of
her children is in a state of public
disgrace that won't stop her from
insisting that prince andrew escort her
at the memorial service for prince
philip last march
andrew may insists he's innocent but
he's been airbrushed from the royal
story because of his friendship with
child sex criminal jeffrey epstein
these days the queen does what she wants
according to her biographer robert
hardman isn't her saying wait you know
wait a minute i'm the 96 year old here
if i want my son
to help me to my seat
i'll just it's taken until her 10th
decade but i think we are starting to
see her being a bit more like the rest
of us and saying you know what i think
i'll do that but i won't do that
and after a lifetime of duty why not let
elizabeth be elizabeth
it seems the least her grateful subjects
can do
it's a crutch the british can't manage
without it
and
maybe that's true
robert lacy has chronicled british
royalty in more than 20 books
we in britain
try to divorce our patriotic feelings
from the political process we have to
think that's that's quite healthy um and
we fixed it on
this
lady who was risen to the occasion so
well
yet any career that lasts that long is
bound to have hit a few bumps
when in 1992 part of her windsor castle
home burned down and three of her
children's marriages collapsed including
charles and diana's
the queen dropped her usual stoicism and
admitted it had been a horrible year it
has turned out to be an anus horribilis
when diana died the queen badly misread
the national room before finally
acknowledging the public's grief
and lately faced with allegations of
palace racism from prince harry's
american wife meghan markle
the queen had to watch them leave for a
non-royal life in california
and that's not even counting the scandal
of andrew somehow though she's kept calm
and carried on
she worked hard she repaired
what she'd done wrong 1997 diana died in
2002
everybody's out in the streets again for
the golden jubilee cheering the queen so
how'd she do it
she did it by
listening she's believed in herself
and because she's believed in herself
because she's believed in her
institution the ridiculous business of
wearing a crown on your head and people
cursing to you but she's absolutely
believed that that is an important part
of
britain
um and its wider family around the world
the english-speaking world um
and um
that's why she has
more than survived there's even a theory
around here that queen elizabeth has
served the monarchy too well that she
may be especially for a son like prince
charles and all the baggage he brings
she may be too hard an act to follow
for cbs mornings mark phillips london
yeah can you imagine following in your
mother's not only your her footsteps but
it's your mother's footsteps and all
that come with that because she is so
beloved and so respected those are very
big shoes
she served too well that's a strong
statement all those years all those
decades all those events always the
black purse yes oh it's a little black
person black shoes that's what she
always wears despite all the color but
she comes from the school of never
explain never complain that's why you
don't ever really know what she's
thinking because wouldn't she be the
interview to get i don't think if she
did one she i think she would choose a
british
reporter
it seems like that philosophy works it
does work it's worked very well for her